you going to eat that well yeah I'll
just get my sauce you shouldn't be
eating meat well it's not meat it's
chicken no it's meat that's wrong it had
a heartbeat it had a life it Soul yeah
but it doesn't have it anymore though no
because people like you are eating me
love we're outside of KFC sorry we're
outside of KFC love yes I know which is
why I'm here trying to educate people
like you about me yeah you're you're
wearing a Lea jacket this is vintage
wait what like this is vintage okay it
was killed many many years ago before
veganism or before any of this was was
you know came to light yeah I'm not
going to throw away perfectly good
jacket it's cold out here yeah I'm not
going to throw away a perfectly good
chicken I'm hungry out here yeah but
they're going to kill the people like
you cows are dying because of the jacket
oh God no you one no I'm not going to be
eating why flesh it's not flesh it's
fried it's not flesh it's fried that
can't be real do you think that's real
it might be real I don't I don't I don't
know